so part of my responsibility as a chief
medical officer health is to inform
ontarians and I think the first step is
educating it's not just covid-19 anymore
we are dealing with the complexity of
covid-19 influenza in RSV and I'm very
concerned that children are being
admitted to our hospitals and are in our
intensive care units principally for and
under that cannot mask so everyone
around them the parent The Sibling the
grandparent I'm urging them to protect
the most vulnerable of us are children
by adhering to all the layers of
protection what might be a call to you
can lead to a severe respiratory
infection in a child four and under so
there is a complexity now that it's
important that all ontarians understand
and we have to get back to the basics if
you have children and you yourself has a
cold that can be a serious and
significant respiratory illness in a
two-year-old or three-year-old so as we
go indoors my principal message today is
to protect our children follow all the
layers of protection our hospitals
system needs us to protect our children
more and more and it's not just masking
it's the layers of protection if you
have any symptoms of infection you
should mask around those that are most
vulnerable to our individuals you should
be screening on a daily basis good hand
hygiene is going to be exceptionally
important with RSV and influenza it's a
call to vaccinate against influenza and
covet as there's no vaccine against RSV
we need to protect our health system we
need to protect each other and it's
really getting back to all of those
Basics we need a reboot a reminder of
what will keep us safe for the rest of
the winter season and today's the key
message of getting back to the basics of
protecting our most vulnerable this is
different than covid this is protecting
our children and those are the youngest
above us please parents grandparents
siblings if you have any respiratory
symptoms you must mask around those that
are vulnerable masking in mandatory
masking in a certain venue may help
decrease the risk at a community level
but I'm very concerned about our
children and protecting our children
right now and it's best that we protect
them through masking in the home
environment and in any social situation
as we go into what will be a very social
environment in winter